[Music]
now you teen Lee point out that we could
eliminate eighty percent of all chronic
disease by using what we know and we
don't do that we really bogged down and
bickering about do we know what we know
and and is this part of what we know
more important than that part of what we
know and and in no place is that a
bigger problem than diet there's
obviously a lot of money to be made from
confusion some years ago I worked on air
for Good Morning America and I saw
firsthand that there really is a vested
interest in TV in the median propagating
constant change if you say the same
thing about diet on air enough times in
a row people lose interest in your
dietary segments if you say something
different every time it's always
interesting tune in tomorrow for a new
answer so the media are in on it the fad
diet authors are in on it basically a
lot of people who just think that their
view of the truth through a particular
tunnel is the only truth are in on it
but the result is we squander the
opportunity to use what we know because
we bogged down and debate about what we
don't know quite so well so having
completely lost my patience for the
status quo decided to do something about
this and it's really challenging now
because there was a time not all that
long ago when a single voice could rise
above the din think for example about
doctor koop when he was Surgeon General
or Benjamin Spock and the influence that
he had on parents raising young children
but that ear is gone because we live in
the age of the blogosphere in cyberspace
and everybody's got a microphone and and
there's just this incredible amount of
static and at the end of it all the
answer to the question can we say what
died is best for health and by health we
mean longevity vitality weight control
all the good stuff that we all want the
answer is absolutely no if what we mean
is a very specific prescriptive my diet
can beat your diet so you know can we
say whether the best Mediterranean diet
is better than the best vegan diet
if that's better than the best Paleo
diet for human health the answer is no
if what we mean though by can we say
what diet is best for health is a basic
theme of optimal living then the answer
is a categorical yes it's incredibly
clear from incredibly voluminous
incredibly consistent literature all
around the world diverse populations
diverse methods observational
epidemiology where you just watch and
see what happens intervention trials
where you assign people to diets
randomized control trials and real world
experience with large populations like
the Blue Zones and frankly Michael
Pollan pretty much nailed this one eat
food not too much mostly plants that
really captures the essence of all of
the world's diets that are associated
with good health outcomes and when I
wrote about this with my colleague Frank
Hugh from Harvard we said wholesome
foods and sensible combinations and then
to put a little meat on the bones as it
were wholesome foods means vegetables
fruits whole grains beans lentils nuts
seeds with or without everything else
you want to eat fish eat fish don't eat
seafood eat seafood you want to eat some
lean meat do you want to eat eggs do you
want to eat dairy do but the bulk of
your diet should be vegetables fruits
whole grains beans lentils nuts and
seeds this is true all around the world
where people do the best it's true in
the Mediterranean where the diets are
high fat but the fat is coming from nuts
seeds olives avocado olive oil it's true
in the far east where the diets are low
fat because there's lots of vegetables
grains and less of the nuts in the
avocado and frankly it's true of diets
as diverse as vegan and paleo people who
really know what they're doing with the
Paleo diet are eating a wide variety of
plants preferably wild plants but not
necessarily and lean meat preferably
game so it's real food not too much and
it is mostly plants and a vegan diet is
a slightly wider variety of plant foods
without the meat but they're actually
more alike than different so there
really is incredible clarity about the
fundamentals of healthy eating and I
think really the big
issue for all of us is focusing our
efforts on making the fundamentals of
that dietary pattern more accessible in
our culture and allowing for people to
choose the variant on that theme that
works best for them so you need to eat
well even in a world that keeps running
on Duncan you need to eat well and feed
your children well in a world that
markets multicolored marshmallows as
part of a complete breakfast you need to
be physically active in a world that
gives you no time for exercise and gives
you more and more technology to do
everything that muscles used to do so
the theme of healthy eating unbelievably
clear the specific claims about my diet
can beat your diet all false all
somebody trying to sell you something
step away from your credit card and
nobody will get hurt
you
[Music]